[Musique]
quand même
bon ça a été pendant des jours bah oui
parce qu'en fait tu pas le choix donc si
tu veux mais bien j'adore tes bout des
doigts ça lui fait pas de cadeau
toi tu es jolie tapas et déjà fait
l'amour dans les vagues sur la provence
ils sont mignons
sam hamad bin non quand c'est sincère ça
n'existe pas j'irai je veux seulement
toi là dessus
[Musique]
savary ouais ben grave aussi
mais j'ai envie de toi de ouf si je
pouvais je serais déjà parti mais je
m'arrange je peux pas demander qu'ils
accélèrent les plats le yoga rénove
complètement
c'est pour moi un pacte on doute
évidemment que j'ai envie de toi je fais
pas montré encore à midi on si je
pouvais je suis en train de tout gâcher
toi non
aucun mal à dominer ses chiens
combinaison peut pas retirer ces
réfections parle d'un petit fait
carrément d'accord mais moi je te fais
pas par un jour papier portant le papier
oui je n'ai même pas dit à ma mère j'ai
pas dis à ma soeur encore bien peut être
je garde jeudi connaissent assez bien
oui jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est
que rita que je savais qu'il atterrisse
hélène elle est vraie alors conscience
là c'est les aider que de la tenir
je suis désolé mais malgré nous mentant
il habite et où attendez je vais changer
ma commande
faut savoir raison garder je fais moment
qu'on lui dit un autre je reviens donc
le real est parti pour elle est partie
je m'y attendais pas je digère cette
douce oui mais bon après c'est patrick
ascquois qu'elles sont enceintes donc
quèsaco cucquois cette dîme c'est à dire
chez eux
racha intéressant c'est compliqué les
secours billettique sur chacun ça moi je
viens dans l'axé ça va elle sera
construit son nid au coeur à la fatigue
était belle
c'était très jeune quand on est très
jeune je te rejoins jetant dessus mais
c'était super jolies tennis mais j'ai
perdu mon frère tu prends sa ronde avec
un coût
[Musique]
aussi des commerçants tous elle est trop
mignonne même s'en foutent pas ça ça ça
a eu un paquet là où ça dans ma vie
n'est plus tout à fait la vraie menace
actuelle
[Musique]
bâle est continue depuis sa voix sur sa
fille qui n'ont rien à manger manger
pour deux donc prouver à toute la
famille non j'ai parlé à ma mère et je
me suis installé racer
vous tenez ces messages quoi jeudi
qu'elle allait mais chez super contente
on dirait qu un peu nerveux j'ai un truc
aussi à tendance et attends je vais pas
avoir trop d'émotions sinon ça fait six
mois qu'on est ensemble
il faudrait attendre combien je pense
que c'est comme si je n'ai rien dit
j'étais dans la voiture je remets ma
tête je me disais si c'est que pour
saisie tatamis du vin j'ai l'esprit
nation tu es quand on attaque
je te rates ton pied et les parties d'un
[Musique]
voyage à sa patronne a laissé bêtement
une boîte pour moi j'ai un mental
d'acier qui va présenter en trois mois
et
et j'avoue tout avouer que on a on s'est
trouvé des points communs
je chéris mais tu sais qu'on s'entend
bien tu sais que ça va bien ça va bien
et est pas toujours là a été trop gâtés
notre jour là du coup on je me suis
confiée et danse confie aussi vrai qu'en
tuque libre manu je sors un peu et dacia
je sors avec toi principalement mais
aussi un peu aidé moi toi ma mission
avec
ce matin temps en temps on se voit on va
finir et on s'entend bien mais avec toi
ça rien à voir attendant je ne le prends
pas comme ça mais j'étais content aussi
[Musique]
avant
pardon et soit vous faites quoi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tu prends aussi beaucoup
[Applaudissements]
les chaleurs
alors aujourd'hui on a regardé on est
con on à votre femme par skype alors et
on à hanoi
ben a cédé 2 voilà c'est donc la jeune
fille et et sa copine est elle est
chouette haine ça ça va mais vous êtes
franchement ouais moi ce que j'ai aimé
c'est quand vous avez dit il est
vraiment le même nom mais c'est vrai
mais ce cas là c'est vraiment le piège
était très très bien si moi j'avais
j'avais du mal parce que je suis pas
comme ça dans la vraie vie évidemment un
pee wee mais presque bon d'être aussi
goujat ça me faisait mal papale parce
que je savais qu'elle écoutait celle
prenait son premier degré j'avais qu'une
peur c'est qu'après elle se sauvera
comme ça tout le monde sait ça bah oui
oui surtout à moi alors déjà qu'on
n'arrive pas à faire un duplex à un
mètre faire on n'est pas prêt déjà si on
n'arrête pas de passer
skype ont pas non plus au matin je
voudrais vous remercier retard et vous
dire que voilà franchement vous êtes
définir ou paris
[Applaudissements]
juste la question est ce qu'à un moment
quand la foudre est fiancée de jean
michel s'est retrouvé tout seul est ce
que vous avez pensé un moment lui dire
eh oui ah ouais moi à oui oui ni non
alors dans ces cas là je vous le dis les
histoires de coupe c'est un petit
conseil que je vous donne pour la
première et ne vous mêlez ça vous
retombe tout sens dessus vous regardez
moi je me suis mêlé de fatou et j'ai eu
ça m'est retombé dessus j'ai perdu
pourquoi j'ai perdu pour 5000 euros de
bagues
merci en tout cas trois sports bercy on
va retrouver benjamin castaldi qui est
bien agitée